autour de justo de gauche à droite aux
idiots platini piantoni et skoblar l'un
des meilleurs quintet de kanye
intergénérations qui se puisse imaginer
la soirée débute par la photo de famille
avec les anciennes 58 auxquels se sont
joints des cra depuis le période plus
récente française ou étrangers chacun y
va de sa petite anecdote lorsque juste
fontaine m'appeler je n'ai pas hésité
une seule seconde à c'est pour moi un
grand plaisir d'être à ses côtés avec
quelques-unes des grandes figures de
foot français une rencontre particulière
c'est un france autriche à paris ou à
colombes où il avait marqué un but
extraordinaire une reprise de volée sur
un centre de la droite de 30 35 mètres
je crois loger en pleine lucarne était
extraordinaire il est passé à l'olympia
sur la scène et où il a chanté je ne
souviens puisqu'elle avait santé mais il
a eu un succès et puis c'est le départ
pour la banlieue toulousaine les agapes
sont prévues à aucamville
21h entrée triomphale des héros de 58
700 personnes debout c'est la gloire
pour juste au pied noir marocaine et à
marrakech il ya presque 70 ans est
toulousain depuis 36 ans un passage
éclair dans le firmament du football
il est écarté des terrains par une
vilaine blessure à l'âge de 27 ans
quarante trois ans plus tard l'étoile de
fontaine l'homme aux 13 buts en coupe du
monde continue de briller dans toutes
les mémoires culot punch générosité 3
moore qui caractérise et juste
résultat de l'usto que de jouer une
coupe du monde en entière c
grosse satisfaction de voir autant de
monde mais maintenant ma peur c'est que
ces 700 personnes sonnailles contente à
la fin du repas il reste certes il y eut
des absents di stéfano cruijff et idan
indisponible et pop art malade mais
bobby charlton le héros de l'angleterre
championne du monde de 1966 était là
juste pour sa part quitté festival se
mêlant de tout tour à tour maître de
cérémonie animateurs conteur et chanteur